and we're just getting word now that the
world anti-doping agency has banned a
Russia from all major sporting events
including next year's Summer Olympic
Games in Tokyo members of the
international body convened in
Switzerland to hand out the four-year
ban they accused Russian administrators
of manipulating doping records a
government-sponsored doping scheme was
revealed five years ago Russian athletes
were barred from competing in Russian
games they have been banned from the
Olympics and World Championships in a
range of sports that decision coming
from the world Doping agency let's bring
in our sports correspondent li Wellings
from London so Li what exactly does this
mean them well this was expected that
wada would impose this four-year ban on
russia to go with the bands we've
already seen over the last four or five
years for what is of course
state-sponsored doping it was their
compliance committee at the world
anti-doping agency that investigated
Russia and realized there was still a
complete lack of compliance there was
still much cause for suspicion there
were still things that didn't add up
when they eventually got the data they
needed and so of course there was the
need for the wilder executive committee
to take action on behalf of world sport
now of course once this happens and
we've seen it before then the whole
situation moves into the politics do we
actually see Russian athletes competing
in for instance the big one the Olympics
in Tokyo next year the answer is almost
certainly yes it will be the same
situation that we saw in Pyeongchang in
the Winter Olympics in the Rio Olympics
before that where Russian athletes who
are perceived clean compete under a
neutral flag this leads of course to a
lot of criticism of the IOC and other
sports bodies that not enough is being
done for a blanket ban on Russia there
are many athletes who miss out on medals
that are furious this is still the
situation and I can tell you there are
loopholes for instance Russia's hosting
of major sports events for games in Euro
2020 in some Petersburg June next year
they're likely to take place because
your wife is not a signatory to the
Wilder Code I've seen other loopholes
that mean that if a sports governing
body feels they can't move an event in
time for practical or legal reasons then
it would stay in Russia inevitably this
will end up again in the Court of
Arbitration for sport in Switzerland
because there is an inevitability that
Russia will deny and appeal